if we re-philosophize where we are and
what does human integrity rather than
human ethic look like what does human
unity rather than human conformity look
like if we start stepping through that
philosophy
the behaviors that we see filling up the
headlines simply disappear
what is the biggest lesson that you took
from 2020
wow you know i think it's hard to
dissect them all
out but i think if i were to you know
take a reductionist approach to that
um i'm i'm ultimately just glad to be
alive at this moment
uh what a privilege to have witnessed
2020
uh it's it's
difficult to overstate the tipping point
situations
that are so multifaceted tipping point
of human health tipping point of
socioeconomics tipping point of
sociology and psychology of
of populations and that just this
extraordinary space to be in so
uh i am walking away with a new sense of
gratitude to the moment that i showed up
in
and so that's i think a way of looking
uh
positively at a year in which so many
people lost so much
and so many people gained so much and in
that
dichotomy uh what a privilege to be
alive what a privilege to be witness to
it all
that's a really interesting take on it
and one that i actually quite appreciate
i i wonder whether there is a
whether there is an advantage to living
through history um
you know like it is it was uncomfortable
you know like
i i preferred 2019 in terms of an
experiential
uh adventurous world than 2020
but you know if you look at between sort
of in the
60s there have been people that have
born and died and had a good amount of
life without actually living through a
massive amount of history
you know um i wonder whether that's
part of something that can add meaning
to life going through something which is
a
global trauma species-wide
civilizational threat
i wonder whether that's something that
can add meaning and is actually
worthwhile living through whether it is
as you say
a blessing almost to to have endured it
i think it is a blessing i think if we
look at the generations that have not
witnessed war or not had to be a part of
war
there's a lethargy that sets in in that
generation and there's a laziness
there's there's a tendency to take
things for granted
in that that group and i think that my
grandfather's
generation really struggled with uh the
younger generations who had not
uh seen global clock conflict on that
scale before
with the flippancy that we would talk
about politics or we would talk about
civil liberties um you know people who
lived through the initial civil rights
movement
and watching how flippantly we've given
away those civil liberties and civil
rights
in recent months and years i think
there's a real discouragement
there and so when we find ourselves as a
new generation that's
in in the mix of massive you know
catastrophic events
or you know conflict uh whether it be
socioeconomic or military or otherwise
we do have to be cognizant that we are
brushing against the very thing that it
means to be aware
and so uh to be aware is to be uh
threatened in some ways unfortunately
the neural network of the human brain
uh is easily distracted and is easily
tempted into the the uh
the softness of comfort uh when we're
not in a fight or flight
state and in that comfort state we tend
to dull our senses
uh we can see this in the way that we
celebrate right we we
order the way which we you know we deal
with bad things you know
you you get fired from your job you go
to the bar you drink with your friends
to dull you dull the pain
you get the big promotion you go to the
same bar you drink with your friends
it's just like what the hell are we
doing as humans like every opportunity
we have to dull the experience of being
alive we do
and so uh there's something that happens
in a year like we just had where where
life can become raw
and if you found yourself this year in
one of those experiences where you just
were
stripped of everything you thought you
had lost your job lost your home
life has turned into a prickly pear of
experience and you're just
it's painful to take a step sideways
it's important for you to realize at
that moment you are the most conscious
you have ever been
you are in some ways having the most
real experience you've ever had and if
for a moment you can
instead of trying to dull that down with
the alcohol or the netflix or whatever
you're distracting yourself with
come into that moment and say man this
pain is really
profound and it's real and i'm real and
i must be real for the experience of
censor
the sensory experience of feeling all of
this
then you can have start to work from
that space if i can feel this much
what would i like to do to transmute
that pain into an opportunity
what would i like to do to transition my
perspective of there's so many barriers
to there's an open door behind me and i
could turn around and go that direction
and so those are the things that i think
if we started that
into the public narrative instead of
saying ah man so sorry you lost your job
of
dude you lost your job you've hated that
thing why you told me last year you
hated your job was killing you
congratulations you lost your freaking
job what's the next opportunity what do
you want to transmute what do you want
to do next
you know if that was the attitude to
loss
that we immediately saw again uh of
gain of function if you will in this
whole viromic talk the
the gain of function comes from loss and
transition
comes from challenge or friction uh so
there's a real excitement that you're
spot on that
we should celebrate years like 2020. not
only is it history maybe it's human
dude i that strikes a chord with
something i've been thinking about for a
long time uh called living with the edge
so very much life can be lived from the
comfort of your couch
and edges are a scary place to be you
know there's a precipice below you
you're terrified that you're going to
fall off
but there's a reason the edges are there
they're there to remind you that this
is how far you can go and you came back
and you were fine
um and obviously there's some
very deeply ingrained issues with
regards to trying to get people
especially in a group
to be okay with comfort because
naturally we want to shy away from the
things that make us feel bad
and even with things that make us feel
too good we often talk about trying to
keep a level head and remain
but dude i totally totally agree you can
go through your entire life within the
middle
interquartile range of experience never
going up towards the absolute joy and
never going down toward the
complete sort of existential loss and
feeling alive like what else are we
really here for like what's the purpose
of us being on the planet is it
is it just to bounce between moderately
okay to not so bad
like for 80 years um
yeah and the statistics are on
post-traumatic growth which i'm sure
that you'll have seen as well it's like
two-thirds of people that go through a
trauma
come out and say that it was one of the
most significant parts of their life
i know it has been for me the mild
traumas that i have been through have
been the things that have made me the
person that i am today
they were the orthogonal turn that
adjusted my life direction in an
unambiguously more virtuous better more
integrity filled way
perfectly said perfectly said and i
think that
that loss is a great example of those
events that
uh demand shift and what a relief
uh and so you know when i lost my job at
the university because of
you know collapse of funding at the
national level the
nih had lost funding because of the big
recession 2008-2010
suddenly our university that had been
funded since 1969
loses its funding and you know on the
human brain level i was
devastated as like i just spent 200 000
of school debt and
17 years in academia to be part of this
university to march into the future to
be the chair of the chair of medicine
someday or whatever
you know bs i wanted for myself and all
this and so when i was losing that there
was a sense of like my
god how much did i invest and how much
am i losing in all this
and yet if i had not had that experience
i would have stayed in the depressed
state that i was in i was depressed
working at the university of virginia as
a chemotherapy chemotherapy developer
and yet i felt then this huge sense of
loss when i lost the very thing that was
killing me
the very thing that was keeping me in an
isolated state and away from my own
purpose
and so the loss of that job you know was
so beautiful
in retrospect of man it opened me up and
when when you have lost i think there's
a tendency for us to try to cling on to
the ledge that we just
stepped off of and we kind of you know
inch ourselves along that ledge with our
fingers tips until we
find some new safe little platform to
stand on
what happened to me and it was not
voluntary because i was in
full terror i was in full fight or
flight state losing that job losing
you know my faith in academia as a whole
realizing i was gonna have to go into
the private sector all of those things
i wouldn't have i wouldn't have let go
of the ledge but every time i tried to
hold on to the ledge
the universe was literally bring a
mallet down on my fingertips and
make me fall and then i would catch a
new new edge and it would
hit me again i went through a series of
events between february of 2010
to about june of 2010 where every single
door in my life slammed shut
and i lost so much of what i had had
been building for 20 years previously
and what it forced was a free fall event
and the free fall was economic
it was social it was professional like
on every level i lost my friends i lost
my colleagues i lost my funding i lost
money i lost
you know nearly everything and over the
next few years
you know my life would would continue to
push those buttons
i would lose my marriage i would lose
all kinds of things that i had built my
identity around and i thought my
character was based upon
and the idea that i would lose my
marriage was just like catastrophic
compared to losing my job like this was
this was my spiritual character now
being taken away from me
and so uh what i went through in those
four or five years was
a continuous free-fall experience of i
have no grounding left i have no anchor
thrown in anything left the every anchor
chain i've thrown out there's been cut
by the universe
and while i wouldn't necessarily wish
that on everybody
or anybody i hope everybody gets that
experience because
what it does is finally force you into
that
existential experience of asking who are
you when you're attached to nothing
who are you when you've lost all sense
of roles and sense of responsibility
and you are just wondering what's going
to happen next you're
you're waiting for the the crashing
death
you know on the bottom of the chasm that
you're falling into
and and then suddenly for inexplicable
reasons you start to feel like your your
descent is slowing
and you're still falling through space
that you've never been in you're still
falling in an environment that you've
never
witnessed you have no anchors but your
descent or your speed of change is
slowing
and then suddenly without hitting
anything you come to a standstill
and that's the moment that i hope
everybody got to in 2020
at some point in 2020 the world made you
stand still
and maybe made your kids stand still
they're finally not running around to 10
000 soccer
things and running around to all of
these other things football sorry
uh you know going from from moment to
moment to moment
they all finally stood still and i hope
as humanity
we take advantage of what happened in
2020 and what's already unfolding in the
beginning of 2021
which is we can't really step forward
yet because we don't know what the
future
that we want looks like and we're
terrified of the future that's unfolding
against our will and we don't know how
to fight it yet
and so we are in a moment of pause and i
think we need to
to celebrate that pause and we need to
ask each other what are you feeling
right now when we when you can't move
when you're paralyzed you don't have the
job you don't have the money you can't
travel you can't get on that airplane
you can't go to the restaurant you can't
do
anything you would have done a year ago
in that pause what are you feeling right
now what is coming to your mind as a
potential
opportunity or a fear that you face
what's what's coming to you
because it's in that slowing of the
descent where you realize
you are no longer going to hit some pre
preconceived
bottom of of the of the chasm
you're about to to find flow and you're
you're stepping into the current of flow
of
the universe now instead of preconceived
realities that you were living within
so when you feel that descent slowing
you find yourself silenced
in some ways that's when you panic the
most because now you're not even moving
and what if you got paralyzed right here
what if you stopped moving
and nothing was real and you had no job
you had nothing ever
and so as you feel the slowing happen
there's i think that's where we see
suicide happening the most
i think that's where you know we see the
deepest depression but if we could see
the 30 000 foot view
that slowing moment is about to be where
we just stop
swimming up the stream we stop
fighting the current we let go and we're
ready to flow into a future that we
haven't seen yet
and that's should be the most hopeful
and optimistic moment of our life and
unfortunately
it can often be the opposite because we
keep clinging to
the previous world the previous reality
so i encourage each of you if you feel
frozen right now if you feel
like you can't move if you feel
paralyzed it means you have come to a
standstill
and if you wait for another couple beats
wait for a couple more breaths
you might feel a little bit of momentum
in a new direction
that's not directed by you not directed
by your sense of responsibility or your
sense of
duty but it's actually the universe
starting to take you into a playful
moment
of what would it feel like if you just
floated downstream with us
instead of continuously fighting the
stream fighting the current so that's
that's 20 20 in a nutshell i hope for
the world
i really love that man i went to go and
see jordan peterson live
about three years ago and someone from
the crowd asked him a question
and they said um the depth of my
consciousness causes me to suffer
basically um it is both a blessing and a
curse to feel everything so very deeply
what can i do about it
and he said you take the thing which
poisons you
and you drink enough of it to girdle the
world around you you turn it into a
tonic
that allows you to fix the problem
inside and that sort of onward deeper
into the breech type
solution to me really does
feel like the only way that you can that
you can find a solution with this
another analogy that i've been thinking
about a lot i had a special forces
british
special forces soldier on the show last
year and he
taught me about a break point which is
when they stack up outside of the door
before they're about to breach it's a
small period of pause in between two
periods of chaos and extreme action
and i wonder whether we've globally had
a a global break point here
where all of the things the flexing on
instagram like no one can flex on
instagram if you've got a mask on you
know you can't
you just can't do it like he's stuck in
your house i know you're stuck in your
house you can't show off your car it's
like you can't drive it anywhere
um and i know that you think a lot about
our future as a civilization
long-term it's something that i've been
very very deep into
i'm concerned that we may have missed a
great opportunity to bind together as a
civilization
uh through this pandemic i'm aware it's
not fully over
um but we have seen still quite a lot of
people coming head to head groups going
up against each other in a way that i
would have hoped a species-wide
suffering might have helped to dispel
what's your
current sentiment on where we're at at
the moment and where we're going forward
as a civilization
well there's there's a saying out there
that there's only two
two true sciences and one is
physics and one is philosophy but since
physics was based on philosophy there's
only really one true science and that's
philosophy
and i think where we're at at the moment
is the need to redefine our
philosophical
sense of reality and this comes around
you know some very important terms that
are being utilized i think
to
in some ways
us into thinking that we are okay the
worst
possible outcome of 2021 would be that
we go back
to some sort of previous normal which is
exactly
what my country just did we just put
into power
a president that was here eight years
you know pre you know for eight years
already 12 years back
and so we literally were so craving some
sort of security we were willing to go
backwards to a previous
normal that took us to the point where
we had everything unfold we had a donald
trump because we had those eight years
of
of this this kind of mindset in in
politics
we had the you know collapse of the epa
and the collapse of everything that
everybody hated trump for the setup
for that was the eight years of the
president and vice president that we
just
hired back in so i'm dumbfounded by the
fact that we can be so short-sighted
and so scared that the only thing we can
imagine is the past
that's terrifying to me if we can only
imagine the past
as some you know some sort of
improvement to our future
we've lost the game and so we're at this
interesting tipping point of
are we willing to let go of the past
and if we are not and if we continue as
a globe to do what the united states
just did and put old thinking back into
place
then we're going to as you say miss the
opportunity for a new version of
community and connection
and co-creation and we're going to step
back into the concept of big government
is better
you know when we need protection against
the scary factions we need protection
against
oligarchs or you know big personalities
so we need
more uniformity and
the philosophies that i think we need to
start to look at is
for example the word ethic
the concept and philosophy of ethos or
ethic
requires a human perspective to even
make a judgment call
on whatever ethic you hold your ethics
are ultimately a judgment call
that are limited by your own perspective
on the reality you live in and so if you
say this is an ethical behavior
you are looking through a very heavily
programmed viewpoint as to what the
reality
and what the circumstances that event is
turning up in
and what the influencer influential
factors are and all that
the transition of philosophy from ethic
to integrity solves for a new future
the word integrity requires no
perspective
integral or integrity meaning that there
is no conflict within
no matter which direction you look at
something it has
integrity it means that all of its
integral parts are aligned and there is
no internal conflict within
it is much different than an ethos or an
ethic which almost by its
its existence is saying that somebody
else disagrees with me there is no
coherence in an ethical field
the field of ethics is one of conflict
is one of debate whereas
an industry or a a being of integrity
has no debate within it has no discourse
of conflict within it
because everything is of in its highest
truth in its highest vibration
so i look forward to imagining
a future nation a future you know
statement of human rights that's built
around
integrity rather than ethic because the
ethic allows for too much manipulation
by political systems communities
individuals
and they can be manipulated to socialism
or communism or whatever it is
and so in the same way we're you know
let me use just one other example
because i know this is a running long
description here
but where we are right now with ethics
to integrity could also be looked at
through the lens of
unity versus conformity and
it's very dangerous that we believe that
the
manifestation at its highest level of
unity is
one of conformity and i believe that
that's
what the current paradigm is using
against us is saying
how dare you not wear a mask or how dare
you
say that we should have you know ethnic
differences or whatever it is
we should all be we're all the same we
should all be the same
when you start to hear unity turn into a
message of conformity
you know that you're suffering the same
consequence of integrity into ethic
which is you are being manipulated away
from your own self-identity you're being
manipulated away from your
own truth when conformity replaces unity
the beauty of unity any union of two
people in a marriage or two people
in a business development or whatever it
is is that you recognize the difference
between the two
that's why there's a contract that's why
it says you are you
i am me and we're gonna have to create a
contract as as something that would
bring
unity into this but at no point does a
good marriage say you have to be exactly
like me you have to conform to who i am
and what i want to do and what i do
a successful marriage allows for
flexibility and growth of the two
individuals over
a course of a period of time that then
creates
you know some dynamic you know synergy
that
as a where the the whole is greater than
the sum of its parts
unity allows for the whole to be greater
than the sum of its parts conformity
dissolves the potential for creativity
co-creation
and a future of hope and so those are
two examples of where i think we're at
you could go through almost every word
in the english language to show the
differences between
a manipu a a philosophy of existence
that's
perspective driven and a philosophy
existence that's
based on on elements of truth i think
that strikes a thread i've been thinking
about a lot recently
and i i believe that it's a
particularly american phenomenon um it's
one of the few countries that talk very
openly about how much we love our
country or at least you used to up until
very recently
um and uh it would be very
emergent bottom-up and very dictatorial
top-down you know the
star-spangled ban is flying behind the
president as he's inaugurated
like i pledge my allegiance to the flag
you know school kids
everything it was everywhere permeated
through the culture you saw this
um and one of the things that
i think you're starting to see now is a
particular minority of people who are
also almost rebelling against the love
for the country
but that narrative is still there and
what that's doing
is it's basically saying i don't trust
that you are genuinely a part of our
team so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to force you to make the mouth
noises that you need to make in order
for me to believe that you're a part of
my team
and that's the difference you're not in
unity with me if you're in unity
i would just have faith and i think when
you expand this out across the globe
i wonder whether a different version of
earth of humans would have needed so
much bureaucracy to
to exist i'm aware that we've over
complicated to the way that we live
right like i'm aware that we are
maladapted for the current environment
that we're in
but it does seem like an awful lot of
complexity that we're going through in a
desperate attempt to
just kind of keep going on
a man like let me just reel off some
stuff that's happened over the last
six months so we've had some of the
black lives matter riots
we've had the capitol hill siege we've
had
this myanmar military coup we've had the
uyghur muslims
in china we've had the russian leader of
the russian opposition
uh being jailed now for two and a half
years that potentially may get moved up
to a decade of forced labor
the leader of the russian opposition
remembering that he only got
um poisoned with a nerve agent novichok
six months ago
we've got the farmers strikes over in
india
man that is glo if you're not in new
zealand or australia
you're pretty close to some serious [ __ ]
that's going on do you have any
conception over
if are these things linked what's
happening here why is this so much
chaos yeah certainly linked and
and interestingly there's biologic
models
that that will parallel the the human
paradigm that you just laid out there so
um you mentioned australia being kind of
untouched by this stuff but it turns out
they had the
largest you know forest fires in in
national history
in that same period of time and those
fires
were caused by a failure
of ecosystem management really and so
in the failure of farmland management
and and the
care of soil and water systems they set
themselves up for that massive fire and
then within months we see the biggest
fires in california history
and through the same process of a lack
of care
and responsibility to soil water and air
systems in those regions
and those played right into the spread
of the pandemic this
you know the viruses bind to the carbon
particulate in the air from those fires
and
and speed spread of all kinds of
pathogens
so there's there's very close links
between human biology and planetary
biology
and so as we start to talk about the
sixth grade extinction which we are you
know halfway through here
we've lost some maybe 40 50 of of life
diversity on the planet in just a short
40 50 years and
we're thinking we only have 60 65 70
harvest left on the planet at the speed
of of the degradation of
arable blands that decimation of the
sixth extinction
has an interesting influence that we've
been studying very specifically in my
laboratory over the last eight years
is is the relationship between the
microbiome and the human immune system
when you lose the microbiome which is an
extension of your macrobiome your macro
ecosystem what air you breathe what
foods you touch what soils
create your food all of that big
ecosystem
actually translates into the diversity
or the failure of diversity within your
microbiome which is your skin your
sinuses
your gut you know every organ system
within your body now recognized to have
another niche
of bacteria and fungi that are living
within that organ
and so we are this teeming organic
garden that reflects the outer world
and the interesting work that we've been
doing is showing that when you lose the
microbiome you actually
lose the barrier between the outside
world and your immune system and the
immune system goes into an overwhelm and
we call it leaky gut we call it leaky
brain
all these things but those terms are are
describing this phenomenon the world
around us starts to
force a complete mobilization of all
warfare at the
inflammation level of our immune system
so we turn into this chronic
inflammatory machine
and when when you show a population
into this uh devastating injury where
you spray
uh roundup the most common herbicide on
the planet you know
four billion pounds of this stuff
sprayed globally every year
when you spray that chemical it
functions as an antibiotic
and and that whole population now starts
to
lose its microbiome secondarily that
chemical happens to break down that
barrier even faster it's a direct injury
to the barrier system between
your gut and your immune system and so
this one chemical gets sprayed and what
you see is a rise in major depression
anxiety disorders and all this
but you can actually see this play out
in politics in the american politics
the stress of the environment of the
individual results in more and more
biologic inflammation and you can see
this that most of our presidential
candidates
will suddenly go into the hospital or go
into you know a week of health collapse
just a month or two before the election
they grind themselves into the ground
and they have a health crisis leading up
to the grinding
into the ground and their
hospitalization if you watch their
speeches
they get more and more animosity and
inflammatory rhetoric in their speech
and so what we see happening in myanmar
what we as he's
happening in all these places that you
just said is
extreme human conflict more and more
divisive inflammatory words actions
militant behavior in a bizarre way i'm
suggesting that is all
symptomatic it's not even a cause it's
not even
you know some root cause problem it's
literally a
symptom of biologic collapse of our
planet we can anticipate
that we will literally tear each other
to pieces in the coming six decades as
we watch the end of this extinction
happen
if we follow the same destructive
microbiologic
approach you know to warfare if we start
killing the microbes
at faster and faster efforts if we fear
all the viruses and we fear all the
bacteria
and we spray clorox all over this planet
you will watch
humans destroy themselves through war
through technology through
any mechanism they can think of because
they're going to be scrabbling for the
last
few you know scripts of bread on the
planet
this scarcity mentality driven driving
itself into the ground
if we turn around there's a whole world
of biodiversity and nature
health and healing waiting to heal the
ecosystems and when we start living in
those environment we simply
behave differently and so we need to re
to
to give a sense of grace i think to
humanity right now
we need to forgive each other and say
you're acting like a freaking [ __ ]
you are an [ __ ] you're destructive
you're
combative you're you're you know
imprisoning your
your opposition you're doing whatever in
russia you're doing whatever myanmar
i actually recognize that that's just a
symptom of a greater collapse of biology
and integrity on this planet and so in
that moment of forgiveness and that
moment of grace and we say oh we're just
all acting exactly how biology would
predict us to act
we need a new biology which would be
based on a new philosophy
of who we are and and where we fit
within a complex micro ecosystem macro
ecosystem
within a complex web of life on earth if
we re-philosophize where we are
and what does human integrity rather
than human ethic look like
what does human unity rather than human
conformity look like
if we start stepping through that
philosophy the behaviors that we see
filling up the headline simply disappear
how do you feel about the development
and the rollout of the covid vaccine
the most fascinating scientific thing
that's ever happened
right and so i've got you know thousands
of colleagues and hundreds of thousands
of
you know audience members and everything
else that have been
following out everything i've been doing
for the last 10 years
and you know you've got tens of millions
of consumers in the united states that
are all reaching for non-gmo products on
the shelf
everybody's starting to be afraid of gmo
and non-gmo watch out for roundup watch
out for this
so you have consumers bending over
backwards to to get only organic food
only this
and now they're lining up for a vaccine
that directly genetically modifies their
children
and that's freaking fascinating and so
from a scientific viewpoint
this is one of the most interesting
moments in in human
history because for the first time not
we're not just saying we're in conflict
with nature
we're actually taking over the reins
from nature and saying we're going to
create a manifest destiny of our own
genomics
and we believe that we know which genes
need to be turned on
which genes need to be inserted into the
human experience so that we
can produce some future health or future
experience
that would be independent of nature
whereas
it's the first step towards a genetic
modification program
to believe that we can be independent
from nature
i find it fascinating i mean it is the
most vile of scientific mistakes on one
level
it is the most extreme hubris of human
behavior
on another side of the equation and on
the
the final you know judgment of it it's
perfect
it's exactly the next step that we
should take because
in doing this we begin the journey into
finding out who we really are which is
a figment of the beautiful imagination
and creativity of nature
of that imagination the figment of the
imagination of nature is beauty
and what we are are delving into right
now
is a really dark dark manipulation of
of genomics and it's
wrapped in this altruistic you know
mission and all of this
but in if you can't handle that news is
to its genetic modification it's
screwing with nature it's that's okay
because
it'll take you a few years to have the
perspective on it because i don't know
what it's going to look like yet
we certainly have a lot of science to
suggest why we should be very concerned
about what's about to unfold in the 12
months
following mass vaccination with with a
vaccine or
vaccine's actually not even a very
accurate term to it this isn't a vaccine
this is
a pure genetic modification the hope is
that it then has an antibody response
similar to what would happen if we gave
a true vaccine
a vaccine is a a debilitated
form of bacteria or a virus or something
like that
but this is the first time we're just
giving a genetic signal for us to make
viral components so that we hope we make
antibodies to it
so so it's not really a vaccine in the
and what i think should be the pure
definition of it
uh but it's an extraordinary genetic
modification
and we won't see the the ramifications
for unfortunately a few months
and and year after you know we've
already done it
and and at that point the the pandora's
box has been opened
and the response to the downsides of
what's about to happen
is going to be a scramble of technology
saying oh well we can patch that up with
this new gene
and this is an this is the new gene you
need this year
and so next year we're gonna have
another multi-billion dollar you know
scheme
in place to say well i we realized that
one missed a little bit and
the virus modified so now you need this
gene to make this protein
and you start to see the slippery soap
you know we have 10 to 31 viruses in our
environment that's 10 million times more
viruses in just the air than our in the
entire
universe of stars and so you've got you
know
this interesting moment where we're
going to start the slippery slope you
need this one protein oh really you need
one protein out of the 10 to the 31
viruses that code for proteins
this is the one protein we're missing to
be healthy and of course we're going to
miss and they'll say well actually it's
this gene that you need next year and
you can see the simply slope where we're
gonna all be
racing for the next uh apple iphone yes
but
just as much for the new gene that we
need next year
and so this is the beginning of an arms
race in science and in pharmaceutical
uh warfare to find the next gene that
that we can create a narrative around so
that humans think they need that next
gene
and we're going to make trillions and
trillions of dollars of
money manifest in this march away from
nature
and in a few scary years we're going to
find out that we we engineered ourselves
into an envelope that has uh that has
secured our
our place far from nature and in that we
will see our demise and
and that's that's the course we're on
but i love human consciousness for its
fickleness
we rarely go the same direction for very
long and so i think we could learn
an incredible lesson from that and
finally start to redirect
everything from science to you know
international funding towards research
and science
in a new and different direction when we
start to realize the mistakes we've made
i promise that i didn't mean to just
talk about existential risks throughout
this podcast but it does definitely seem
like that's what we're stumbling upon
um the next hundred years really are
as tobeyed calls it the precipice i
think for humanity
the potential advent of artificial
general intelligence
and misaligned super-intelligent agi
um is the biggest as far as he's
concerned a one in ten chance
that it causes us to go extinct
within the next hundred years and he
gives our chances of making it through
the next hundred years
at five out of six so there's a one in
six chance that between all of the
different things engineered pandemics
natural pandemics
uh nanotechnology the unknown unknowns
the natural risks the anthropogenic
risks everything bundled together
the more that situations like this occur
the more that
we believe our own hubris i think that's
a good word like a civilizational hubris
um a over quoting of the naturalistic
fallacy
as well the more that we do that
the more it seems to me that we are
stacking the odds
in the favor of us running straight into
the great filter
whatever that's that may be and maybe
we've already passed it
maybe the great filter that stops
civilizations from reaching their full
genetic potential
their full civilizational potential and
colonizing the galaxy
perhaps we've already got past it maybe
it was prokaryotic to eukaryotic life
maybe it was the presence of liquid
water maybe it was whatever whatever it
might be
and maybe we've got past it and maybe
we're going to fall at the hurdle of
thinking that we're smarter than nature
and only in retrospect are we actually
going to know what the hell we should
have done
yeah yeah i i think that's the
opportunity and
you know on our current course i think
if we don't have a fundamental change in
philosophy
then the systems of economics the
systems of technology
information technologies in particular
uh those systems will
will accelerate and i think the the the
one out of six is
is actually very optimistic um if we if
we maintain our current philosophy
but there's a lot of things that i think
could occur
that we can't quite imagine yet that
would instantaneously
so fundamentally change our entire human
human experience and human philosophy
and one of those would be the
the visible appearance of
a global appearance of some of our
neighbors and so
if we have intelligent life visit this
planet in a visible fashion
and we are presented with a diplomatic
uh a diplomatic front of four or five
other species that live around the
universe
and they show up here to have a
discussion of where we are
and where we could go uh everything
would change in an instant
spiritual our spiritual identity our
scientific identity our philosophical
identity all would change in an instant
when these these other uh species show
up
we tend to call them aliens and then it
sounds like a conspiracy theory and all
this but
i i really believe there's a high
likelihood that we are seeing
signs and and and symptoms of
intelligent life
bumping into the planet here and uh
what's that what like what life what
signs what signs have you seen what
signs
i think that uh one of the telltale
signs of it is
is sudden sudden innovations or insights
that percolate up through
the planet simultaneously in in a
multifocal fashion and so instead of
one group innovating and coming up with
a new electric car and they call it
tesla and they go
see that thing all over the world in a
new monolithic company
when i see sudden breakthroughs and
intelligence or or
psychological mindset happening all over
the planet simultaneously
i interpret that as a high one of the
high likelihoods that's occurring at
that point
is a shift in the the frequency
resonance on the planet and one of the
ways in which that would happen
is people in that residence which you
know in in the residence i'm talking
about i'm talking about maybe
what people think of is consciousness
but it's actually consciousness is kind
of like ethic where it requires a
perspective
is really about a knowledge field and
the way in which knowledge
emanates and manifests life in the
universe is through vibration
and so vibrational changes on our planet
are happening that are
changing the philosophy of humans and it
manifests as
new technologies it manifests new forms
of communication and education
all kinds of things shifting and uh
and so there's without going into things
that you know specifics that i think are
replicated because then we will have an
opinion about them well maybe that's
that and they'll have a thousand
different things
that general concept of why would
suddenly the earth shift its
vibration such that all of us would know
something new you know
and i think that if you start to look
around at the world around you
you'll realize we are starting to make
these seismic shifts in awareness these
seismic shifts
in our sense of self and our potential
to change the world
if you if you can't find the evidence of
that in yourself then look to children
right now
watch a group of autistic children
together and see how they
see the world and see what reality they
create around themselves
and then you come to terms with maybe
there's one in 25 humans on the planet
with
an autism spectrum disorder right now at
least in the
industrialized nations at those numbers
and then
and that number might be as high as one
in three by by 2035 in 15 years
and so humanity is literally changing
its neural wiring
it's manifesting in things like autism
spectrum and asperger's and some of
these hyper-intelligent
different ways of looking at the world
are they aliens
no but they are tapping into a vibration
of consciousness
that we haven't had access to before as
humanity
and so i think we're becoming vulnerable
to an opportunity for cataclysmic shift
in awareness
and i think that if there are other
intelligence species out there they're
sensing that opportunity
and if any time in human history they
were going to show up it would be about
now
because we are seeing this dichotomy of
of the collapse of human consciousness
and and the rise of human consciousness
as it's
talked about widely and so i think
there's an opportunity
here where a single touch from from a
neighbor
another species would really
fundamentally change everything
instantly
and so you mentioned not wanting to talk
about existential threats but it is
if we're going to mention those it's
also fun to think about existential
corrections and existential healing
moments and one of those would be
we're not alone and we're on our perfect
path we had to get to this
stage of scientific and you know
innovation socio sociologic innovation
we had to go through the the fits and
spurts of of human
respect and integrity to get to the
point where we could handle the news
that we're not alone the universe is is
working towards biodiversity in all of
its sectors and we could
play on that new sandbox level of the
galaxy or the universe
and that's what we're being called into
next and so now nobody's worried about
how big monsanto is or whether 5g is
good or bad or any of these things
now it's a discussion of how do we sit
at the feet of higher intelligence
species
and let them learn from us we are one
hell of an emotional species which might
be one of our most unique aspects
they i'm sure are are in wonderment over
i wonder what it
feels like to be in such emotional
conflict as humans are able to feel i
wonder what that feels like
and so maybe we're here to demonstrate
something to the greater universe
because the universe is certainly not
asking us to conform
i think it wants us instead to be in
unity but not conformity
and it wants to bring all of our human
weirdness and all of our human
quirkiness
into this ecology of of higher
intelligence
that is something that i've only just
realized
i would be interested to know if you
agree with me
that i think it would be difficult for
any sufficiently advanced alien
civilization to be
much more emotional than us because
too much emotion too much emotion
reduces your ability to coordinate
and you need quite high levels of
coordination in order to be able to
achieve anything as a civilization
if you ramped up our emotions by another
20 or 30 percent
i think you have nation states falling
apart i don't think that you can hold
companies together i think that people
are
fighting in the workshop on the floor of
spacex
i think the pilots are punching each
other as they're taking off from the
from the tarmac so
that really is a an insight i've never
even thought of before i'm a bit
gobsmacked i haven't thought of it but
it would be difficult to imagine
a more emotional civilization than
ours because they just wouldn't be able
to get anything done
you're spot on and and that really comes
down to the individual level even so
you know as a physician i've very often
seen
very functional individuals uh tumble
into
psychotic breaks and uh in a psychotic
break your emotions
uh start to dictate a new reality you'll
hallucinate
you'll you'll you'll have visual
hallucinations auditory hallucinations
you'll have new paranoia
you'll create a whole new narrative in
your head about the reality you live in
within moments and you know it only
takes a few seconds of neurochemistry
perturbation to that emotional cascade
in your in your tiny little part of your
brain called the
hippocampus to lead you down this
completely false
uh pathway uh that that actually usurps
your own self-identity
and so not only would we be
dysfunctional as a society we would be
so dysfunctional as individuals if you
when you rash it up the emotional you
know codex even slightly
uh 20 would probably be you know
catastrophic but even
even a five percent uh you know increase
in our
in our uh in our subjugation to the
emotional brain
renders us useless you know we've talked
so far about some fairly scary
terrifying
topics and it has been a difficult 12
months for pretty much everyone
worldwide what would you say to people
who are wanting to
be a little bit more robust mentally
what are some of the insights that you
use for yourself around mental health
and what would you tell them
to be able to hold on to and to value so
that they can
keep themselves level over the next 12
months
i think i would move back to you know
what we were talking about earlier about
the moment of silence or the moment of
of where movement stops
you know if you can create that pause
and and
do that daily to listen long enough
for a new reality don't even have any
preconceived conceived notions of what
that might look like
maybe you'll think about your life maybe
you think about your relationships maybe
you think a bunch of children whatever
it is
but allow yourself a few minutes a day
to go into a completely silent state
where you try to bring all the molecules
in your body into a state of
pause so that it can pick up on the
subtle
tones the subtle messages the subtle
energies
that will point you in the direction of
the flow of the real universe the bigger
universe
that's that's guiding and you know
forming
uh the human experience in its tiny
little
sector of the reality we live in and so
free yourself up of the human mind for a
moment and make yourself an antenna to
the universe to say which way are you
flowing
which way is the planet flowing put me
into alignment with that
and then when you open your eyes back up
start to reimagine
everything that was just taking up your
mind your relationships your job your
the book you're reading the netflix
series you're watching whatever it is
and start to
to inquire is that in line with what i
just experienced in the silence
and if it's not lose that thing as quick
as possible
and re-imagine it in the form of you
know something that is aligned with it
lose your your previous perception of
your partner
and imagine a new relationship with that
partner what if you let them
be somebody completely new in the next
millisecond and
what if they let you be somebody new in
the next millisecond
who would you both become what would be
the potential of it
it seems like too many options too many
things but you will know exactly which
direction to go if you took the silent
moment
so take the silent moment allow the
atomic structure of your body to align
with a flow that you are not in
alignment with
right now and allow for redirection to
happen
and then imagine yourself untied to any
previous
identity role whatever it is self
self perception free yourself up and see
if you can bring into alignment a new
manifestation of who you are what you're
here to do at the tipping point of human
history
man that would be that would be
incredibly beautiful if everyone was
able to do that
there's a concept called the mindfulness
gap that corey allen talks about and
that
uh interjection the break point between
stimulus and response
is the single greatest gift i think i've
got from meditation and it still
only occurs once every 100 times but the
times that it does
i just think like it's the best gift i
think i've ever given myself as well
you know one of the most useful skills
that i think i've acquired
um moving forward what do you think the
future of health over the next few years
has in store i know that you're massive
into the microbiome into gut health into
top soil management into all of these
different things what do you think is
going to be
the future of health
uh i i i can't see one future i i see
multiple futures and they are
uh extremely dichotomous you know you
can't fit one next to the other uh
we're not going to have some blend of
these futures it's either going to be
the devastation of the sixth extinction
and and
the human health will continue to
decline all the way into our extinct
experience or
you you find pockets of humanity that
begin pilot projects of a new humanity
and that might be a nation-state it
might be a community
but i think we're going to start
decentralizing the human
human experience so that we can start to
do these pilot projects and
that that would allow a great amount of
experimentation and so
if you started to imagine unplugging
from the current current narrative the
current paradigm
and saying what would i do at the
household level
to bring myself and my children and my
my friends family into alignment with
nature in the way that we eat breakfast
well first of all we'd have to touch
nature and so what if breakfast was we
all ran
out with our cup of coffee and tea in
hand and
sit in the garden and harvest a few
things that we'll throw into the skillet
for breakfast and so we're going to
start in
gratitude and receipt from nature and
maybe it's a tiny little vertical garden
in the backyard or next to our front
stoop or maybe it's a huge you know
csa that's down the street or a farmer's
market nearby
we begin the day connected to nature and
then we start to to
reorganize around that um so it's going
to be in these small little pilot
projects
at the mental level and at the at the
execution level uh that we start to
imagine a different future um but it
that future can't exist in the common
narrative and so
you can't think that you're going to
somehow go to the gym enough to avoid
extinction it just doesn't work that way
you
you literally are going to be
extinct with the rest of biology on the
planet unless you can create a microcosm
around you that turns into a macrocosm
and so that begins in your own thought
process and your own behavior
but i think you're going to find out
because of this high intelligence state
that we're starting to have access to
you're going to be able to start to
attract people to you that are of like
mind and of like
like experience and of complementary
skill sets that
could could start to scale your idea to
become a community to come
become greater never before have i seen
so many
millionaires leaving california to buy
swathes of land and inviting everybody
they know to hey do you want to set up a
homestead
you know no topanga canyon's like
emptying out and at los
angeles at this insane rate well we have
like farmland in idaho and all this
stuff getting bought up at
extreme rates so this is this is what i
mean when i think i see
symptoms of higher intelligence sharing
with us
information streams and we can pivot in
a moment where
people who have never on a farm are
suddenly buying farms because they just
have
received information through that
subconscious silent moment
to say oh my god i was doing the wrong
thing i'm it's somewhere over here is
the right direction i'm willing to dive
in completely
um so this is happening all over the
planet right now and so make yourself
part of that future
that we can't quite see i think there's
many versions of that future
and it's really up to you uh what what
future comes to manifest itself and and
what role you play in it
you're an md you've spent a lot of time
palliative care
all this time doing research and working
one like proper
spitting sawdust in the trenches stuff
and then the research and the podcasts
why do you talk with such a spiritual
edge
to the things that you do coming from
that background
yeah i guess you know spirituality is
you know a word that we've
put on it i think it ultimately it's
philosophy again
you know is that if we don't find
fundamental truths that then
shape the direction of our actions
we are lost and so we can talk about
life and death situations we can talk
about macroeconomics we can talk about
politics we can talk about
you know health systems whatever we want
to talk about but if they're not pinned
down
fundamentally on truth uh then then it's
just somebody's opinion
and so the reason i try to always tie it
back is to make sure that i can access
my anchor points that are now in
in philosophical spaces of integrity
instead of ethics
of unity instead of conformity and you
know start
finding those those bricks in your
reality
that allow you to move not only within
your own
you know self-described specialty or
something like that but you're going to
find out that it's fractal
once you find truth it will apply in
every other scale of life every other
specialty of life every other
environment that you can think of
truth always scales horizontally
vertically through all systems because
it cannot be separated from any other
element of nature
because nature has integrity which means
there is absolutely no conflict but
between or within any of the truths that
make up that whole thing that we call
nature
and so that's maybe where uh all of my
podcasts and and public appearances come
back to is
you're going to start to see some of the
truths that have shaped my life
and when i say them you're going to pick
them up and go build a different life
for yourself that i can't even picture
or
experience because you already know what
to do with them because you just found a
truth
and you're going to go do something with
that
zach thank you so much for today man we
didn't even touch on
essentially anything that i thought that
we were going to talk about
um but that doesn't matter because we
have time and we can do this again
uh if the people who are listening want
to find out more about your work and
are younger and iron health where should
they go
yeah we've got zackbushmd.com is like my
educational environment so
lots of access points to everything i do
through that website
is theachbushmd.com
you've got ionbiom.com is the science of
the of the microbiome and how it
is impacting human health we've got a
whole product line there with gut health
sinus health
skin health product coming out as well
so understanding the role of the
microbiomes communication in
in human rates of repair and
regeneration has been our expertise and
it's a really compelling
argument that biodiversity and
communication is the fundamental heart
of biology and it's a good template for
you to start to live your life by so ion
biome ionbiome.com
find you that our nonprofit is
projectbiome.com
i'm sorry.org projectbiom.org is the
nonprofit
and one of our first big projects was
farmersfootprint.us
we're also just launching a sister one
in australia with
project biome australia coming off the
ground so
in that space you discover why
it is so necessary for all of us to be
part of the revolution of chemical
agriculture into regenerative
agriculture to reset the biology on the
planet for a future that is less
inflammatory
that is less divisive and allows for the
integrity and unity to come back in so
projectbiom.org we'll find you all that
nonprofit work
and you'll you can keep exploring with
us if you want to
deep dive on just an educational
experience i started the global health
education initiative a few months ago
the first topic was the virum an hour
and 20 minute
lecture that i think will just
completely blow your mind as to what
viruses are and
and what we know about them and how
everything that's happening in the last
year is completely old science that
dates back
at least 50 years a lot of it 100 years
old and is erroneous and so
blow your mind over what's already known
about this the beauty of the virum and
and how it supports and is fact the
source of human life not against it
and blow your mind there the innate
immune system we just did is much
different than the adaptive immune
system that they want you to think about
around vaccines the innate immune system
is actually what keeps you in balance
with the virum
and then coming out in just a couple
weeks is a
a big project that i've been working on
for almost nine months and i'm calling
it what happened last year
and so it's a big look at at public
health and how we
can use public health statistics to
manipulate a global
narrative of who we are and where we
belong so
global health initiative there at
zachbushmd.com uh
we'll get you into all of that stuff so
lots of ways to engage and i look
forward to staying engaged
man thank you so much for today thank
you for having me on chris
[Music]
you